help me about bringing this wonderful
sixties period to life on the big screen
the clothes the music what was it like
it was certainly a blast I think you
know we definitely had a lot of fun I
mean off screen and on screen but um
yeah oh we got to we got to sing all
this beautiful soul music and wear
sequins and beehives and that's our job
you know so it was really great to exist
in that time yeah i more than like
working with Chris O'Dowd know he really
is naturally funny I mean he's just
exactly the way you see him is is what
he is a film you know but it was it was
certainly a pleasure and to have him you
know be with us and help tell the story
was yeah phenomenal yeah oh he would he
would seriously say something funny in
the middle of a take and we would have
to try and keep it all together and it
was and even when when it was called cut
we still had to just burst out laughing
he was he was a great energy to be
around only you guys know it for them of
course they knew before this film you've
got acting school what was it loves it
like yeah yeah yeah me and Shari did so
we've known each other since back then
but the three of us me Shari and Jess
all come from the same hometown so yeah
it's really it's really great to have
that background it helped us bond yeah
but we we definitely became closer than
closer than anything during the while
filming so yeah it's we're sisters for
life family for life and yeah and we're
going to continue telling this wonderful
story about the sapphires yeah
you